U.S climate Envoy John Kerry ended his
visit to Beijing saying the two sides
had successfully restarted Corporation
and would work intensively in the
lead-up to the cop 28 conference in
Dubai we had very
conversations but we came here to break
new ground
which we think is important at this
stage
and it is clear
that we're going to need a little more
work to be able to complete that task
which we still believe both of us is
doable he said the two sides agreed on
the urgency of the climate crisis both
the US and China are experiencing record
high summer temperatures
over four days Kerry met with several
Chinese leaders including vice president
Han Jong
St was the boosting of renewable energy
and the curbing of coal consumption and
non-carbon dioxide emissions
is necessary for China the United States
and indeed all countries in the world to
strengthen coordination build consensus
and the speed up action
Kerry said he hoped bilateral tensions
would not get in the way of fighting
global warming which should be treated
as a standalone issue Chinese officials
described the envoy as an old friend but
said climate change could not be
separated from the overall environment
of U.S China relations these are the
first climate talks held between the two
sides since their suspension in August
when former U.S House speaker Nancy
Pelosi visited Taiwan climate change is
one of those few issues where there is
an alignment of U.S and Chinese
interests it sits in the foreground and
in the background we have a whole host
of incredibly fraught incredibly
contentious issues
that contention was felt during a
Communist Party environmental conference
hosted by President Xi Jinping this week
she said China was committed to its goal
of achieving carbon neutrality by 2060
but its path would not be dictated by
others Kerry denied that was what he was
trying to do there was no
there was no there was a clear exchange
of ideas if anything is dictating
it is the science
China has bristled at U.S criticism of
its new coal-fired Power Products State
media says China already draws 30 of its
energy from renewable sources John
Kerry's visit ends as the Chinese
Capital sets a new record for
consecutive days of high temperatures
Wednesday is the 28th day above 35
degrees it's currently 38. the previous
record in Beijing was 26 days and that
was set 23 years ago
sweltering heat a reminder of the need
for the two superpowers to produce Real
Results on climate change Katrina you Al
Jazeera Beijing
fires are raging across Greece